foreign
my name is Ken o'nell
I'm an assist I'm an associate professor
of pediatrics at the University of
Chicago I'd like to thank you all for
joining me today here in TV land or
computer lab I suppose
um and uh what I'm going to be talking
to you about today is uh work that we've
done in our lab looking at the role of
genomics and trying to understand the
ideology of cancer as we as we go
through that presentation what I'd like
to do is ask as you come up have
questions you just feel free at any time
to type them into the Q a box and um at
the end of the presentation we'll uh go
through them all together and
um there you have it so why don't we get
started so I as I mentioned a few
seconds ago my laboratory's particular
interest is in trying to understand how
genetics contributes to cancer risk in
response to therapy
um as we all know we are I'd like to of
course uh mention I have no Financial
relationships to disclose
um but with regard to our interest in
cancer and the contribution of the
genome to cancer risk of course we're
not alone in that lofty goal our hope is
to use the information that we learned
to predict cancer susceptibility to
individualized cancer therapy and to use
genetic factors to identify new targets
for novel rational clinical Therapeutics
now as we all know
um while that is of course the promise
of genomic medicine and cancer the
reality hasn't lived up to that promise
and there are of course a number of
reasons why so here's an illustration of
you know of of where we stand in terms
of thinking about genetics and cancer
this is data from one of my absolute
favorite studies performed by Doug
Easton Paul Farrow and Bruce Ponder
looking at susceptibility to breast
cancer in a very large group of British
women either with or without breast
cancer ultimately the study encompassed
roughly 30 000 cases women who developed
breast cancer at 30 000 controls women
who did not develop cancer so on first
blush the study was a rip roaring
success if you look at the p-values for
Snips that were identified as being
associated with breast cancer ideology I
mean we see numbers like 10 to the minus
76 in experimental science of course we
should live so long as to see numbers
like that but when you look at the
effect size this Victory is not so clear
so here for example we see effect sizes
for the top Snips the most associated
Snips emerging from the study of 1.26
1.11
1.09 so on and so forth and of course
what that means is that in the general
population if the risk of developing
breast cancer is one in a hundred should
you be so unfortunate as to carry the
snip that's most associated with an
increased risk for breast cancer your
risk goes from that one in 100 to a rip
roaring 1.26 and 100. so the question
that has to be asked is who cares
um and you know why is it that the
effect size of these Snips is so small
so you know people have tried a number
of ways to sort of do better
um one idea that people have had is of
course to ask a bigger study another
idea that people have had to sort of
overcome the barriers to using uh
genomic information clinically is to ask
an even bigger study but I perform an
even bigger study but you know our idea
is rather than asking a bigger study
perhaps the right strategy is to ask a
better study a smarter study uh the
first step in performing a smarter study
is of course to ask why is it that the
effect sizes that have emerged from
these previous studies has been so small
and so clinically of limited utility
um and uh while of course there are a
lot of possible explanations for that
our task was to step back and see if we
could come up with our own
hypothesis as to why that was and our
reasoning for where we wound up is as
follows if you think of cancer as a
complex disease what that means of
course is that it um results from the
actions and interactions of both genetic
and environmental factors
um if you think of these environmental
factors each of them
um
UD radiation ionizing radiation
cigarette smoke so on and so forth uh
elicits its own cellular response
pathway and each of the cellular
response Pathways this is on the set of
genetic determinants and so we
hypothesized that by not controlling for
non-genetic noise that is variation in
ideologic exposures that are associated
with cancer risk all you're going to do
is elicit genetic noise
um essentially garbage in garbage out
and the consequence of that the
inevitable consequence of that is that a
genetic signal would be attenuated so
our challenge was to come up with a
method by which we could essentially
control for that non-genetic
heterogeneity and heterogeneity control
for that non-genetic noise
um and the strategy that we arrived at
was to study second cancers that is
therapy-induced cancers the idea is that
these therapy induced cancers are
consequence of antecedent exposure to
cytotoxic therapy that exposure uh has
is the same for cases that is cancer
patients who do develop these
therapy-induced Cancers and controls
that is cancer patients treated with the
same agents who do not develop these uh
therapy-induced Motors
as a result because the exposure is the
same for the cases and control
non-genetic noise is essentially removed
from the equation
and the only factors that are the major
factors that distinguish cases from
controls are their genetic differences
and so we hypothesized that by taking
advantage of second cancers we would
facilitate our ability to detect genetic
risk factors for cancer because we would
remove the confounding effect of not of
a variation in non-genetic factors uh we
thought that these second cancer genetic
studies would provide a unique window
into genetic susceptibilities for cancer
and because we're not looking at
individuals or families that are
genetically loaded we thought that we
might also learn uh something about in
gene by exposure interactions that are
associated with risks for sporadic
cancer
first study are made in foray if you
will into the world of uh second
latencies therapy of these cancers was a
study we performed a couple years ago
looking at therapy related AML or taml
so therapy related AML is a particularly
devastating form of second cancers uh
survival is measured in months
um unfortunately currently it represents
10 to 20 percent of all cases of AML
um it is cytogenetically characterized
by two major subtypes one that is
associated with antecedent exposure to
alkalinity agents that comprises roughly
75 percent of all cases of therapy
related and now and is characterized
cytogenetically by acquired
abnormalities of chromosomes 5 and 7.
it's also characterized clinically by a
relatively long three to ten year
latency to the development of AML with
an antecedent MDS phase the other
subtype of um therapy related AML is uh
that that is is the subtype that's
associated with anteceding exposure to
topo2 inhibitors effect constitutes
roughly a quarter of all cases of
therapy related AML It's associated with
specific Gene translocations
particularly involving MLL or ml1 and is
also clinically associated with a very
short latency so one disease two major
subtypes We performed a very small uh
genome-wide associations that AG loss
looking at only 78 cases and 148
controls
Force our peer-related AML listed on
this slide are our top 10 hits top 10
independent hits if you look at the rank
what you'll see is the numbers are not
sequential and that's because some of
the some of the top 10 associations were
not independent there was more than one
snip tagging a single Locus okay
um now
as you might imagine there are there's a
reason and we'll get to this why three
of those top ten associations are are
highlighted but we'll get to that in
just a minute so
um the University of Chicago set was our
Discovery set so perform the G loss in
uh those 78 cases and 148 controls we
turn to our friends at Washington
University in St Louis for a replication
set which was comprised of 70 cases and
95 controls the expectation or the hope
when one performs these genome-wide
Association studies is that you would
discover set of associations and then
replicate them in an independent second
set of cases and controls
um if you look at the University of
Chicago set what you see uh under the
MAF Collins are the minor allele
frequencies for each of the 10 Snips
first in controls and then cases what
you can see is that there's a very large
difference that's reflected in a very
small p-value when however you look at
the Washington University replication
set
um unfortunately sadly for us what you
see is that while the control minor
level frequency is essentially the same
as in the University of Chicago control
uh set the case uh minor level frequency
is very very different and is in fact in
almost every case very similar to the
minor level frequency that's seen in the
controls and so what that suggests is
that for these top 10 associations we
were not able to replicate any of them
naturally we were upset in trying
cavities for a while but then of course
we returned to the science
um and when we actually looked at our
University of Chicago Discovery set of
cases and the Washington University
replication instead of controls
um you can see their clinical
characteristics on this slide but there
was one thing that was particularly
notable if we look at the proportion of
cases in those two sets that carried the
the chromosomal abnormalities of
chromosomes five and seven remember that
those chromosomal abnormalities are
associated with antecedent exposure to
alkylating agents what you can see is
that they're vastly different now if our
original model is correct that different
exposures elicit different cellular
response Pathways with their own set of
each with its own set of genetic
determinants what this implies is that
in the study our Discovery set and our
replication set were in fact not
comparable but uh rather represented two
different
um diseases right with different
ideologies because the cytogenetics were
completely different and the two patient
subsets so uh what we did was we
returned to our Discovery and
replication sets and rather than taking
all treating All Therapy related AML
cases as equivalent what we did instead
was we conditioned on the subset of
cases for both the discovery and the
replication set that had these acquired
abnormalities of chromosomes five and
seven and here what you can see is that
the results were very different
um if we think back to the breast cancer
genome-wide Association study that we
had discussed previously it took 30 000
cases and thirty thousand controls to
come up with a handful of associations
that were replicated now here we took 10
systems is 10 snaps and attempted to
replicate them in a second
second uh cohort and if you look at the
three uh Snips that were boxed
previously up it turns out that the
boxes have moved for which I apologize
um but look at the three Snips that are
immediately below boxes and what you can
see is that the case frequency which had
been very discordant in the overall data
set now by conditioning on um on uh on
on patients that have the same somatic
mutations what you can see is that for
snip number three snip number
um five I guess and uh no I'm sorry for
for the for the RS 139 4384 I'll just
read the numbers for
um RS one three eight one three nine two
and for
rs1199098 you can see that in now after
controlling for
um differences and acquired cytogenetic
abnormalities suddenly for those three
Snips the minor low frequency in cases
was essentially exactly the same in both
Discovery set and the replication set so
our hit rate was 3 out of 10 which is
remarkable in a genocide Association
study so we were very excited about that
and what that suggested to us was that
in fact our hypothesis was likely to be
true that by conditioning on
um
um in this case surrogates of shared
ideologic exposures we would potentiate
our ability to identify shared genetic
susceptibilities and in fact that is the
major lesson from this pilot G Watts
that we had performed in therapy related
AML by conditioning on exposures common
to cases and controls we can reduce the
genetic noise due to exposure noise we
can enhance our power paradoxically even
as the sample size is reduced
and what we can also do is uh is used in
the case of therapy related AML shared
driver mutations such as acquired
abnormalities of chromosomes 5 and 7 as
surrogate markers for these shared
ideologic exposures and therefore share
genetic susceptibilities
so after completing this genome-wide
Association study we were encouraged to
turn our uh hand to another second
cancer
and and see if we could repeat our
success or build Upon Our Success in
this case what we did was we turned to
Second cancers in survivors of Hodgkins
so Hodgkin's lymphoma as I'm sure most
of you know is uh is a lymphoma
uh it uh occurs predominantly in the
mediastinum so the chest wall the major
method of treating patients of hydrogen
lymphoma is uh radiation
um and it turns out that the risk for
second malignancies in survivors of
Hodgkin's disease is associated with
radiation exposure and it occurs the the
second cancers occur primarily in organs
that are in the field of radiation that
would be of course the breast and
thyroid most commonly
um
important to note as well that the risk
of these second malignancies is
inversely associated with age of
exposure to radiation so patients with
Hodgkin's lymphoma who are treated with
radiation for their Hodgins lymphoma
under the age of 20 are at a very high
risk for the subsequent development of
these second cancers whereas patients
who are treated with radiation through
their Hodgkin's lymphoma under over the
age of 20 are at a much lower risk for
the development of these second cancers
the study that we uh performed was
undertaken in collaboration with a child
to cancer survivor study the ccss this
is a multi-institutional retrospective
cohort study to investigate the
long-term consequences of pediatric
cancer and the effects of its treatment
in survivors the inclusion criteria for
the ccfs is very simple you have to have
been diagnosed and treated for cancer
between 1970 and 1986 he had to have
been under the age of 21 at diagnosis
and he had to survive at least five
years today there are about 14 000
survivors who are still followed uh by
the ccss this represents about 70
percent of the overall cohort and
underscoring the importance the or the
the over-representation of second
cancers and survivors of options
lymphoma it turns out that of the 802
second cancers that have been diagnosed
in the CCS cohort to date it turns out
that 13 of
um Hodgkin's lymphoma survivors have
developed these second cancers whereas
only under five percent
um of survivors of all other
malignancies have um developed these
second cancers so really this is a
radiation problem that is vastly
overrepresented in survivors of Hoskins
and that was the rationale for our study
I I also want to point out that second
Cancers and survivors of Hodgkin's
lymphoma is not just an important or an
interesting to us at least
scientific problem but it's one with an
urgent clinical uh need as well because
it turns out that the second leading
cause of death in survivors and patients
with Hodgkin's disease is our second
cancers second only to relapse so this
is a big deal clinically as well as an
important scientific question
um so for our study we were able to
obtain germline DNA samples from almost
100 Hodgkin survivors who did develop
second Cancers and ADT Hodgkin's
survivors who did not develop second
cancers but were all treated for their
Hodgkin's lymphoma with radiation
therapy
one thing I'd like to point out is that
uh the latency uh for the development of
the second cancers is quite long it's 20
years and so what we did was we required
that all of our controls had survived at
least 20 years plus one standard
deviation that is 5.5 years in order to
ensure that our controls were not
um future cases that had not yet
declared themselves okay so the idea was
that by taking into account latency when
choosing controls we would really
minimize the likelihood that we would
maximize the likelihood that we had a
pure control data set
and this uh figure is a Manhattan plot
uh it shows the results of our
genome-wide association study for those
of you who haven't worked with Manhattan
plots on the x-axis is prison is
um is is plotted the position of each
snip that was genotyped in our study
um as a function of each chromosome for
the study we did genotype almost a
million steps throughout the genome on
the y-axis is plotted the negative log
of the p-value of Association so the
higher
um the the dot is on the y-axis the more
significant is the association of that
genotype snip and um and second and risk
for second cancers following radiation
therapy and Hodgkin's Disease survivors
the red line that you can see at about
seven uh represents the threshold for
genome-wide significance so any snip
that surpasses that threshold uh is
actually a significant education in our
Discovery set and what you can see is
that there are three steps that surpass
that threshold two on chromosome six and
uh another one on chromosome 18. now as
with the therapy related amlg loss the
bar in these genome-wide Association
studies is not just to discover but to
replicate and so what we did was we put
together not one unfortunately again
there's a formatting issue
um with this slide for which I apologize
uh we put together two replication sets
one remembering keeping in mind that
risk for these second cancers is much
higher in individuals who are radiated
under the age of 20. the other of
individ so that the first control
replication set was individuals who were
treated for Hodgkin's with radiation
under the age of 20 and the second uh it
is comprised of individuals who are
treated with radiation for oxygen
lymphoma over the age of 20. and then
what we did was we tested the
association of each of those top three
steps the ones surpassing the threshold
of regina-wide significance
separately in each of these two
replication sets and the results are
shown here this is what this is a
representation of what are called Forest
plots
um the red and blue lines represent the
two chromosomes six Snips the green line
represents the chromosome 18 step and
what you can see in the upper right hand
corner is the RS number of each of the
three Snips themselves okay if we look
first at the bottom of the slide what
you can see is that so if we if we so so
the lines themselves the the thick part
the black the the square box represents
the actual odds ratio of the association
um and then the two lines spreading out
from either side represent the 95
confidence interval if you look at the
x-axis
um the odds ratio is plotted uh and you
know any association that touches uh one
um an odds ratio of one is by definition
not significant so if you look at the
replication cohort of individuals who
are irradiated over the age of 20 the
bottom Forest plot you see that none of
the three steps was significant
on the other hand if you look at the
replication set for individuals who are
radiated for their Hodgkin's lymphoma
under the age of 20. what you can see is
that the two Snips that are on
chromosome 6 are both significant so it
was really cool was that we had
discovered and replicated uh two
associations both on chromosome six that
were associated with a predisposition to
Second cancers falling Hopkins
um as will as we'll sort of underscore
the next slide if you look at the odds
ratio in these replication sets the the
numbers aren't 1.09 1.11 1.26 but are
actually much greater 2.52
1.69 so as you would expect
in these small sets uh the odds ratios
have to be very great for them to be
detected and detected significantly but
in fact we were able to achieve that
well it was really cool is that we're
calling that risk for second cancers is
greatest in those
um irradiated under the age of 20 are
genetic results reflect that
epidemiologic observation it's we have
an association that was discovered and
replicated in individuals who are
treated under the age of 20 but nothing
in individuals who are treated over the
age of 20. so that was a really nice
sort of
um
genetic echoing of the epidemiologic
data if we look in the combined
Discovery and replication set here on
this um in this graph is shown the odds
ratios for each of the two Snips on
chromosome six and you can see 3.21 and
2.43 which are of course astronomical uh
effect sizes to emerge from a
genome-wide Association study so the
next question of course is what are
these steps and where are they so here
is a blow up of the region of the two
snaps on chromosome six that shows both
directly genotyped and orange and
imputed in the blocks net in the black
uh Snips in the region of chromosome 6
q21 that's tagged by the two snaps that
emerge from our genome-wide association
study
um again uh if you look at the dotted
line that's the threshold for
genome-wide significance what you can
see is that the two Snips that were
directly genotype the rs-494 snip and
the rs-104 Snips are the two that have
the highest degree of association with
um with second cancers falling Hodgkin's
lymphoma and what you can also see is
that the two Snips are themselves very
close to each other uh it turns out that
the two Snips are rough leave four
kilobases apart from each other they're
in moderate LD with an r squared of
about 0.4 they live in a region
intergenic between two genes prdm1 which
is also known as blint one and atg5
which is an autophagy Gene that enter
genetic region is itself roughly 70 KB
and if you sort of look at the Peaks
what you can see is that the two Snips
and the large number of other Associated
genotype and imputed steps are also both
within a single recombination block
which defines a group's groups of snips
that travel together
now when we conditioned on one snip we
found that there was a residual
Association remaining for the other step
and that's important because what that
indicates is that the two Snips together
tag the true functional variant better
than either snap does alone and so what
we did was we decided to perform
functional studies to see if we could
get at what the what the mechanism by
which these these Snips were associated
with radiation radiation carcinogenesis
and we did so by creating a haplotype of
the two steps since they together
provided more information than either
alone what we did is we defined the risk
Capital type as have as the haplotype
that has both risk Snips okay and we
defined the protective haplotype as
having both protective alleles okay so
risk haplotype both risk alleles the
protect of half the type both protective
Wheels okay so then the first thing that
we did was we asked whether
um these Snips were associated with gene
expression for uh
any Gene that was that it was within 10
megabases of the two snaps in the
rationale is that when genome-wide
Association studies were initially done
the hypothesis was that the Snips that
would emerge would be Snips that changed
amino acids it turns out that that's not
the case it turns out that most of the
Snips that are emerging from g-wash
studies uh function by altering uh
transcription so to either change levels
of a message or they somehow affect
um enhancers or some some other uh
function uh like that like enhancer
repressor functions or alternative
splicing forms of of genes of
transcripts
um and so the and so to test whether or
not our snaps were likely to be an
enhancer for prdm1 atg5 or any other
Gene within 10 megabases in either
direction of the two Snips we asked we
took a data set of expression for which
we also had full genotype information
and we asked whether the haplotypes uh
risk protective or intermediate
homozygous risk homozygous protective
are intermediate or associated with uh
levels of mRNA for any of the genes
within that as it turned out 20 megabase
window and it turns out that the
haplotype was associated with expression
of only one Gene and that is pure dm1
and what you can see here is that in
individuals who had increasing dosage of
the risk haplotype they had lower uh
significantly lower
expression levels of prdm1 mRNA okay so
what that means then is that the
haplotype is an eqtl an expression
quantitative trait Locus for prdm1 okay
with more
risk equals lower transcript okay so
that's great for message but the
question is does it happen any meaning
for the protein and we'll get to that in
a second but before doing that if in
fact our haplatite
represents an enhancer one would expect
then that we could see that by looking
at
um
um at levels of unprocessed transcript
in the context of the protective
haplotype
um
and so that's what we did what we did
was we in the red you see steady state
mRNA levels for prdm1 mRNA uh at
variable times following irradiation in
the blue you see levels of the primary
transcripts of the unprocessed
transcript
um following radiation and what you can
see is that in the context of the
protective cells homozygous for the
protective half blood type there is a
significant increase in primary
transcript
um thong radiation uh with that Echoes
and proceeds uh levels of the steady
state transcript arguing that
um the the region tagged by our
protective haplotype
um tags and enhancer for prdm1 although
it's not shown in this slide when we do
the same thing in the cells homozygous
for the risk haplatype there's no change
in prdm1 message levels either primary
transcript unprocessed transcript or
steady state mRNA and so taken together
what those observations indicate is that
the protective half the type is indeed
an IR inducible that tags in the IR
inducible enhancer region that regulates
prdm1 transcription which is really
exciting and interesting okay so now
let's ask the question what happens to
the protein right that's message is that
echoed uh in protein and so to test this
what we did was we took throughout the
three cell lines that are either that
are homozygous for the protective
appetite and three cell lines that are
homozygous for the risk half the type we
either let them we left them alone
growing exponentially or we treated them
with radiation and then looked at levels
of pure Dam one atg5 remember that was
the option of the other side of the
haplotype and just as a loading control
Ram
and what you can see
um is a couple of things that are
incredibly interesting right first what
you can see is that
um Baseline levels of prdm1 is much
higher in the context of the cells
homozygous for the protective appetite
then cells homozygous for the risk
appetite uh second you can see that
following the radiation although this
gel is a little bit blown out
um you can see that uh there is a
significant induction of prdm1 following
radiation in cells homozygous for the
protective appetite whereas there is no
induction of Pyridium one in cells
homozygous for the risk Capital type if
we look at atg5 we see nothing happens
and and of course if we look at our
loading control we see that there's
roughly equivalent loading in this gel
throughout the experiment okay so if we
then move to the next slide and expand
that experiment to not three cell lines
but rather to four cell lines
um and then plot out the data we see
quantitatively the same thing so first
um if we look at cells the the the pink
box uh that represents the four cell
lines homozygous for the protective
appetite the blue boxes are cells that
are homozygous for the risk Capital type
um and what you can see is that uh in
cells homozygous for the protective half
the type first basal levels of prdm1 are
significantly greater than in cells
homozygous for the risk appetite and
then you can see the following radiation
whereas
prdm1 levels rapidly uh increase and
remains
remain significantly increased through
at least four hours following the
radiation in cells that are homozygous
for the protective haplotype there is no
induction of prdm1 in cells that are
homozygous for the risk Capital type so
what we see is that following radiation
um prdm1
um in the context of the protective
haplotype is radiation inducible but
it's not so in the context or the risk
appetite okay so and this is important
and interesting it echoes the eqtl data
because remember the risk Capital type
was associated with lower levels of
prdm1 expression and we see that that's
also the case in the level of protein
so that's great but what does that mean
in terms of radiation breast
carcinogenesis well it turns out that a
gene that is commonly altered in
radiation breast carcinogenesis remember
breast is one of the most common uh
types of second Cancers and survivors of
Hodgkin's uh lymphoma
um you know in these patients and in
cell lines that are designed to reflect
the radiation carcinogenesis Paradigm
um what we know is that Mick is often
significantly altered we also know that
the major function of prdm1 in the cell
is to act as a transcriptional repressor
and in fact one of the targets of prdm1
is Mech so we hypothesized is that uh
Nick would be differentially regulated
by prdm1 in the con following radiation
in the context of cells that are either
homozygous for the risk or homozygous
for the protected haplotype and to test
this we again took four cell lines uh
homozygous for the risk for cell lines
homozygous for the protective appetites
treated them with radiation and in this
case we plotted for mac and what you can
see once again pink representing the
protective half cells homozygous for the
protected appetite blue representing
cells homozygous for the risk Kappa type
is that following radiation there is a
rapid and very significant repression of
prdm I'm sorry of Nic in cells that have
their homozygous for the protective
prdm1 half the type in contrast uh the
repression of Mick
um is slower and less significant in
cells that are homozygous for the risk
Apple type so what we've been able to do
is mechanistically go from a genome-wide
Association study in which we identify
the haplotype to the gene to the
function of that haplotype in
differentially regulating
prgm1 induction Fallen radiation to
actually showing that that matters for a
gene that's involved in radiation
carcinogenesis that is Meg so that's
really cool and you know really sort of
takes the study from beginning through
the mechanism
so
um having having done that our next
question was to ask what is the signal
transaction pathway from radiation to
prdm1 now we know that in other contexts
prdm1 is uh induced by NF capital B in
the context of other cellular forms of
cellular stress such as ER stress so we
hypothesized that perhaps NF Kappa B
um was also a critical inducer of prdm
one following radiation and to test this
we again took cells that were either
homozygous for the protective appetite
here in blue or homozygous for the risk
half the type here in red uh we left
them either untreated which is the first
two columns and we see the expected
differences in prdm1 Baseline levels we
treated them with radiation we see the
induction of prdm1 in cells homozygous
appetite but not in cells homozygous for
the risk appetite and then the final
pair of bars uh we pre-treated cells
with a chemical very specific NF Kappa B
inhibitor and then treated the cells
with radiation and what we observed was
that NF Kappa B blockage uh completely
abrogated and prevented uh prdm1
induction by radiation suggesting that
the signal transaction pathway from
radiation to prdm1
involved and as chapter B signaling
um
so we then uh turned our attention to
trying to identify the actual
um snip that was tagged by our haplotype
uh this
um figure over here is a blow up of the
region that is tagged by the haplotype
uh the green box shows you the prdm1
gene region itself
um the region that is Downstream of that
is the entire region that's tagged by
the by the haplotype
um and to identify uh know that that
that there's an enhancer that's tagged
by the haplotype our first hypothesis
was that it would be
um something that altered NF Kappa would
be binding site and while in fact there
are several NF Kappa B uh enhancer
regions that are enhancer sites that are
in the region that are tagged by the
haplotype there's no genetic variation
that exists in any of them so what that
means is that it's highly unlikely that
our SN our haplotype tags uh a snip
that's in an NF capital B enhancer
region so what could it actually be well
we used a variety of
um uh bioinformatics tools to try to
winnow down uh our choices in that
relatively large 40 KB uh real estate
region we looked at marks of DNA's
hypersensitivity marks of open chromatin
RNA pole two binding
evolutionary conservation and we sort of
sum that information together over the
region and that led us to identify for
possible for candidate enhancer regions
that
um might be tagged by our haplotype
um
that we referred to as E1 through E4 uh
to
um sort of in conjunction with that
analysis we also performed an
integrative bioinformatics analysis that
we hoped would lead us to the actual
functional step so here what I've
plotted for you using the Thousand
genome database is all of the genetic
variation that is tagged by our
haplotype
um what we have plotted here to orient
you is the negative log p-value of the
association between all of those Snips
and
um risk for second cancers following
Hodgkin's Disease the two Snips that are
marked in the blue are the two steps
that uh surpass the threshold for
genome-wide significance in our GMOs
um it turns out that this very same
region was has been identified as being
associated with both rheumatoid
arthritis and um and lupus both of which
of course are B lymphocyte disorders as
well so invoking the concept of
pleiotropy that is things converge on on
the same pathway or the same Snips
um we hypothesize that perhaps the same
snip was associated with both ra and
lupus and with the predisposition to
Second cancers following Hodges disease
um and so here uh are the the the Snips
in that region and
um they're LD they're linkage this
equilibrium with the most associated
steps from either the lupus G wasses or
the room chart arthritis g-was
um now in this and then we've also shown
here the regions of open chromatin uh in
that in in
um in this in this small genomic region
um now the reason that we did this was
because we expected remember tag snaps
only tag a region a functional snip if
we're right should be associated with
all of the different
um G1 studies and should also exist in a
region of open chromatin
um we were able to take advantage of the
fact that uh one of the genome-wide
association studies one in lupus had
been performed in a Chinese population
and Chinese and Caucasian individuals
different LD structures and so that we
hypothesize would help us winnow down a
possible candidate Snips that might
actually be tagged by by our Locus and
so the first thing that we did was we
observed that the two candidate enhancer
regions E1 and E2 uh sort of existed in
between regions of genetic variation so
there were no Snips that are in either e
y or E2 so those are gone if we look at
E4 while we see that the association
between
um between the while we see that E4
exists in a region of open chromatin we
see that there are no steps that are
associated with
um
with lupus in the Chinese population uh
and what that suggests is that in fact
enhancer 4
this doesn't contain the functional step
because again functional snip should
cross ethnicities if we look however at
E3 what we see is that there's one snap
that is uh highly associated with
um with all the different diseases and
all the different ethnicities and lies
in a region of open chromatin and that's
marked by this Arrow uh if we ask what
that snip actually does we see that it
lies the rs115 snip we see that it lies
in an sp3 binding site sp3 is a well
characterized transcriptional repressor
and if we look at open chromatin what we
see again this is shifted somewhat uh
from its original uh version what we see
is that
um the the snip itself lies in regions
of open chromatin and in in at a site
for RNA pole2 binding so taking it all
together other we hypothesize that
enhancer 3 was likely to contain the
true functional snip
um tagged by our half the type and that
that snip itself was very likely to be
the 115 snip
um to test this hypothesis we first
performed a luciferase reporter
experiment to look individually at the
four different candidate enhancer
regions
um and you see here the plasmid Vector
that we used for these studies so
there's an sv40 promoter driving sip
Rays expression which you can just
measure experimentally what we did was
we cloned into that bam H1 site and you
can see uh each of the four different
candidate enhancer regions the
hypothesis is that a functional enhancer
is going to alter luciferase expression
and what we saw was that only
um the only enhancer 3 is one that we
have predicted informatically was
functional it did in fact alter
luciferase expression suggesting that
the functional snap tagged by our Alpha
client in fact does lie in the answer
three regions
um suggesting that in fact the snip
itself that we identified in The sp3
Binding site was functional
um we looked at RNA pole T binding
across the region
um of the snap and what you can see is
that uh the TT
um
TT represents cells that are homozygous
for the protective version of this of
that snip the CC represents cells that
are homozygous for the risk version of
that step RNA pole two uh binds to
regions of active transcription so an
answer promoter regions and what you can
see is that exactly what you would
predict that there's increased RNA pole
tube binding
um in in cells homozygous for the
protective uh version of the snip and
they're as decreased RNA pole tube
binding
um in in cells homozygous for the risk
version of this step and this leads us
to two conclusions first it leads us to
conclude that in fact this snip is truly
a functional snip okay so it actually
matters and the second thing is that uh
the the
RNA pole tube binding Echoes what we
would have predicted for or a snip that
sits in a in a repressor region okay and
that there is less
um expression immersion cells homozygous
for that sp3 site then there is in cells
that have destroyed the sp3 okay and the
final experiment that we did was again
looking at function We performed an
electron electromobility shift assay in
which we uh took in all the nucleotide
that contained either the risk allele or
the protective allele we
um washed it with uh with with protein
extract and
um then we asked about The Binding of
that protein extract to our our to the
labeled version of our oligonucleotide
probe and uh what you can see is first
if you look at the bar graph on the
right hand side the proteins nuclear
extract bound more avidly to probes that
were that contain the risk allele then
to probes that contain the protective
allele suggesting that in fact the
nuclear extracts contain some sort of
transcriptional repressor right and then
what we can see is that when we washed
off uh that the The Binding by by
competing it off with unlabeled probes
to sort of draw off the nuclear extract
um that there was
um it was more difficult to draw off the
the nuclear the nuclear protein uh from
cells that had from probes that had the
risk allele then
um instead that more specificity uh when
we used probes unlabeled probes that you
know have the risk allele than um probes
unlabor probes that have the protective
allele suggesting that Not only was The
Binding of this nuclear protein to the
risk um nucleotide Not only was it more
Avid but it was also more specific okay
um and so again that suggests that this
is truly the a functional step
so now taking all of these data together
what's our model our model for
um how our snip actually or how our
haplotype actually is involved in
um in in
response to radiation is that in the
context of the protective uh allele of
the rs11 instead of The sp3 Binding site
um sp3 cannot bind to that enhancer site
rather RNA pole two and NF Kappa B can
bind and they elicit transcription of
pure gam1 in the context of the risk
that we all remember we generate an F
Kappa B I'm sorry an sp3 binding site
sp3 binds that enhancer site preventing
pull 2 and MF cap would be from binding
uh to the enhancer the promoter and
thereby abrogating transcription of PR
dm1 in response to both baseline or
limiting in response to radiation and
also both and at Baseline as well okay
so that's that's how we're thinking that
our snip actually or our haplotype
actually is associated with radiation
and carcinogenesis so
um
the question then becomes uh this is
great in second cancers where there's
this very large and very focused
exposure to radiation but does it have
any relevance for sporadic disease so
this is actually difficult to test and
clinically very important since as we
all know radiation exposure is
ubiquitous
um so what we did to test this was we
turned to a collaborator Yuri nikafarab
who has been studying for a number of
years survivors of Chernobyl and what we
did was we asked whether one of the
steps that was associated with radiation
induced second cancers was also
associated with risk for radiation
induced thyroid cancer and survivors and
children who survived Chernobyl and the
point that I want to make is that while
the sample set it was extremely small uh
what we observed was an effect size that
was in the right direction and almost
achieved
um uh statistical significance
suggesting that the region that we
identified may be involved not just with
risk for radiation induced second
cancers but with risk for radiation
induced primary cancers as well so
what is the meaning of all this why is
it that we spent all this time doing
these sorts of studies well the answer
has to do of course with cancer
susceptibility right now so as well as
being a researcher I'm a clinician and
my clinic is dedicated to familial
cancer trying to help families that may
have an increased risk of cancer
understand why that is and help them try
to identify
um
perhaps strategies by which they can
minimize their increased risk of cancer
the problem is that right now we have
very few tools that we can use to help
us in this very important task uh we
have only family history of cancer and
personal history of cancer and because
families are small and because
um people don't necessarily know their
family history and because it's it's you
know there are lots of reasons that
people die other than cancer
um we are very limited in our ability to
actually utilize these these Clues
to perform clinical risk assessments for
for families and for cancer risk and we
can only identify very highly penetrant
cancer risk
um susceptibility
genes such as brca1 or brca2 of course
associated with predisposition towards
hereditary hereditary ovarian cancer
so blunt dot these are blunt objects
very very crude measures of assessing
cancer risk
um you know
if we think about the results of our
GEOS I want to sort of turn it around
from presenting the data as odds ratios
to presenting the data as something that
I think is actually much more clinically
relevant and that is uh genotype
specific penetrance and uh what I mean
by that will become clear in just a
second
if we look at the first box The Orange
Box what we see is that overall by 30
years following radiation roughly 18 and
a half percent of survivors of Hodgkin's
lymphoma will develop a second
malignancy
um if we look at individuals who are
homozygous for the protective haplotype
it turns out that by 30 years following
exposure to radiation uh only about
three percent of individuals have
developed a second latency in contrast
if we look at individuals who are
homozygous for the risk Capital type
what we see is 30 of them uh have
developed a second cancer so three
percent versus 30 percent that is
enormous and that to me is a very
important clinical clue I mean the
penetrance of uh are are are are
haplotype
um is almost uh brca2 level penetrants
the important point two important points
are one it's only in the context of
radiation so if you look at the results
of a g was of just breast cancer you'll
never see uh our Snips emerging not even
at a nominal p-value threshold 0.05 and
second look how common these Snips are
it turns out that 50 of Europeans are
Caucasians are homozygous for the risk
haplotype and so what that means is that
they're very very common very very
penetrant but only in the context of a
specific exposure it's a context matters
right so
um I think this has a lot of potential
implications for the way that we think
about cancer risk and I think that one
of the important implications is that it
may suggest that we may be able one day
to go from thinking of cancer risk as we
do right now basically one size fits all
we have these very few very blunt
objects that we can use to
um think about cancer risk to hopefully
in the near future uh be able to do
something that's a little bit more
precise but what we can do is think
about genetic susceptibilities in an
exposure driven way oh you um have are
highly predisposed to develop cancer
thong radiation exposure and so your
risk prevention strategy should be avoid
radiation we can do this sort of
analysis or use this sort of strategy
for a variety of different uh exposures
and I hope that we'll be able to then
achieve a more subtle method by which we
can you know assess an individual's risk
for cancer
so with that um as our time is drawing
to a close I think I too will draw to a
close
um our conclusions from the study are
first a hypothesis driven g-was can be
successfully performed and I think
that's an important point because one of
the big criticisms of these genome-wide
Association studies is that their
hypothesis is free and
um at the same time very expensive and
so because they've had such a limited
clinically the results have had such
limited clinical utility the question is
why should we bother doing them so in
fact I would argue that we can do
hypothesis driven she was and the
results can be quite powerful
um by taking into account exposures we
can see that these exposures are
important drivers of genetic
associations that are associated with
these specific malignancies we've seen
that common variants can have very large
effects but only in the right context
and conversely
um we've discussed we've touched on that
the fact that variants even with very
large effects in the right context can
appear neutral when that context is not
taken into account
um based upon the data that we've
discussed uh I would argue that we can
conclude that prdm1 is a radiation
responsive tuber suppressor uh prdm1 is
associated with radiation-induced
Cancers following
um
radiation-induced carcinogenesis
um it's induced in individuals that have
the protective half the type but not
individuals that have the risk appetite
and that haplotype differentially
regulates
um you know a key mediator of radiation
carcinogenesis that is MEC
um one other take-home point that I hope
has come through is that you know four
studies such as these because they're
predicated upon a shared exposure the
sorts of follow-up experiments that
we've discussed today
um readily present themselves we know
that this is a radiation phenotype so
take cells of opposing genotype or
radiate them see what happens
um and then the final point that I want
to make is that I hope that ultimately
integrating these sorts of G bye
interactions into genetic studies may
lead us to a time when we can use this
information Nation to contribute to
clinical decision making as an example
shouldn't an adolescent woman with
Hodgkin's lymphoma be treated with
radiation therapy I think is an
important question that we may be able
to address in the near future
so I'll stop there I want to thank the
people in the lab and our collaborators
who actually did the work the work that
I described to therapy relate and how it
was performed by Jeff Knight Soph navora
who's a current grad student in the lab
has been following up on some studies
the second cancer after Hodgkin from the
studies were performed by Timothy bass a
superb graduate student who um who
recently finished his time uh in the lab
um the ccss were wonderful collaborators
for this and so I thank Les Robison
Smith Louis strong and Stella Davies who
are the leaders of the ccss and we had a
variety of collaborators including Wendy
cousin uh from USC and Andrew school who
made all of this possible
um we couldn't have done it without
their help and also without the help of
my close friend from Newcastle James
Allen so I stopped there I thought that
you guys should actually see the lab uh
this is us this is from our brief foray
into musical theater
um as you uh will
I cannot will will be relieved to know
we were forced out of uh musical theater
and sadly have returned to science so
thank you for your attention
um if you are interested in obtaining
CME credits for this talk uh the website
is here on the on the screen
um and at this point I'll be happy to
take any questions so I see that the Q a
box is blinking let me open it up
um
and uh
I just see
um Dr o'nell thank you for for your
presentation this is from Darlene
um
I believe
I don't see a question that's attached
to that
um so if there are any questions uh this
would be a good time to enter them
um thank you thank you Darlene I am glad
that you enjoyed this presentation if
there are any other questions I'd be
happy to take them now
foreign
it appears that there are no further
questions
uh so
I guess with that
um once again I thank you for your
attention and
um
will
um I guess that's it then
um
thank you
I guess we can log off now